I just saw 27 minutes downstairs of the
show it's awesome look it was awesome
that's the word also yeah fans are not
ready for this thing one of the things
that I took away from it is and what I
loved is your character is minimal
dialog can you sort of talk about that
aspect that it's almost like he only
talks when he absolutely has to he is
very much a figure in this story that
that is a way of you know inviting you
into this into this world and I think
that the idea literally just opening my
mouth and seeing have no idea what to
say I do I do
you're you're so stoic take it and
powerful and mysterious yeah I think
that's what we loved about Boba Fett
like we loved that the missing the
mystery of a bounty hunter and like
you're just you're you're powerful
historic there's something about him
that is very ancient in a way even
though you know we're talking about
whatever the future is but there's
something about that character that's
very ancient in his monk-like way you
know moving from town to town from
village to village from universe to
universe from planet to planet whatever
that thing is doing why would he say a
lot he's an observer and he responds and
he has a course of action based on this
little one that he has kind of adopted
so I just find it the character to be
one of the kind of seminal characters in
in every genre that you know is dramatic
in its own way he's a lone wolf you know
and that's a beautiful thing why would
he say he's in character immediately
went into character it's interesting how
we work that out
I want at least I'm gonna be out of time
in two seconds I'm curious for the three
of you for each of you reading these
scripts what maybe surprised you about
eat about reading them and what do you
think is gonna make Star Wars fans
really happy Wow what surprised me was
how well-written the stories are each
episode I mean they're really written
well so you can read it you can imagine
and you can see the story what's gonna
make Star Wars fans love it the fact
that Jon Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni are
so into the Star Wars world in universe
and George Lucas himself is so much a
part of this how can they not love it it
is it is the outer rim of Star Wars and
I feel like it's the perfect they
figured out how to make a perfect
combination of the old and the new where
yeah I just think that this plays to the
fans and I think they're really going to
enjoy that you know somebody had their
best best interest in combining what we
loved about the older movies and the
things that we liked about the newer
movies and I think this is a really cool
combination of them it's like everything
that you know and everything that you
want with a little with with extra
personality and flavor when I read the
scripts you know like all the familiar
world of Star Wars all this new stuff
and then and then a little extra venture
the adventure goes out into of the outer
rats aboard it's even it's even more of
a dangerous world than what we're used
to so that just kind of pushes the bar
in terms of what we can what we can do
and what you can expect you know